you guys wanna hear he's gonna be here
not her here ah [ __ ] blur to him look at
Angela cerumen hat avatar headline okay
[Applause]
Lisa joy
[Applause]
in your puzzle ghetto harnesses son park
at we side form and of course telecom a
shark well they're all here most of them
are real you'll find out at the end
which is not panelists are you ready to
panel eyes okay I have a couple have a
couple comments to make
first of all level of detail in the
world incredible
that makes me relax when I when I want
to show the way people are holding their
weapons correctly it's really nice the
size of a hat and the way it's more than
the angle of the head of the person it's
a huge deal having really believable
user interfaces on small tablets which
can fold up to a really convenient size
that can be put into a back pocket very
quickly and then throwing away that
technology because we don't need to
explain that is also a welcome addition
when the actors freeze and the camera
continues to pan but there's still
perfectly frozen it's amazingly well
done there's a little nub on the bottom
of the barrel of some of the pistols
which I conclude is a differentiator
between androids and humans a little
device there I'm probably wrong and just
like to say things like that basically
overall I just want to thank you guys
for creating a show that doesn't pander
or just expect people to keep up with it
it just is what it is and we go along
for the ride no matter how confused we
are which I never am and then you figure
out later on oh that's oh that's why so
anyways thank you so much for appealing
to our higher intelligence
Lisa I have a question for you were
there any challenges in revealing the
character arcs to actors in stages as it
shows - and how do you think this method
benefited the series - telling them in
season yeah the tranquille we didn't
tell the actors anything and yet we're
still friends
I never should throw that project yeah I
know we should see if they forgive us
for that that's that's the key question
I think is only not silent I actually
respect you more well in a way does that
kind of generate almost a quasi
real-time unveiling of the progression
of the character's life so so
essentially each each step is just a is
kind of as much as the character knows
as much as the actor knows I'd like to
think it was like that but you guys all
busted us at certain points like I read
avenues busted me you busted me not me
she busted you yeah
correcting me wonderfully well I mean
you listen now to our show right about
how you how you broke me when you've got
spoiler you figured that oh well I
figured things out yeah I just started
piecing it together and then kept coming
up to you and certain people and looking
at their reactions I think I went up to
you and I was like I can't figure out
who why it is and it's driving me crazy
and I've gone through everything and
I've looked at each person and I'm like
asking around to see if they've cast him
yet and I've turned away every rock
except mine Jonah Jonah and he just
laughed and shook his head and walked
away and I did I questioned it you know
I'm on to something we would all do that
just right on either it was I actually
felt like it was really altruistic as of
you guys not to tell us everything
because as you've seen from watching the
show some of the storylines and and the
things that are happening to these
characters are so huge just trying to
wrap your head around it so a xanax
you just want to having enough to to
digest you know and like if we'd known
everything it would have been too much
our minds would have been scrambled
so I actually felt like it was
incredibly kind to just give us what we
needed so that we could give everything
for that section and then when we're
done with that
we move to the next moment it was and I
don't know how you managed to control it
so that we all had enough but it was
seamless it was really seamless I just
went on reddit thank you but our job as
actors it's generally to not give away
the ending of the story that we've just
read and have gotten excited by in it
you know going after and for them to
withhold this thing that part of our
craft is generally to withhold from the
audience we didn't have it so we had to
focus on what was happening right then
that's all we knew I thought it was the
greatest like acting lesson I've ever
been given and I'm so grateful for it so
thank you thank you I love it I want to
burn out I want to cut the ends of my
scripts every job this year we're giving
you fake scripts yes it really helped me
a pretend to be super smug because I
always thought I was right and had no
idea that pretending robot Tandy yeah
was May's decision to get off the train
and go back for a daughter her first
conscious choice is she going back to
her daughter yeah I don't know
well she better be that's what we wrote
I mean oh god I don't know um had the
first conscious no no I mean I'm just
thinking really pragmatic er I can't try
and be clever now I think that her
decision at every moment to get the
clinicians to upgrade her and to to give
her information they're the first
conscious decision and at every break at
every moment when she discovers
something new she's breaking down
you know so the conscious and it's
interesting that her conscious decisions
come from chaos comes from things
breaking down you know I just think it's
fascinating I'm so into the existential
stuff on the show just that in moments
of chaos when you think you know nothing
that's when gifts come you know I just
think that's incredibly profound and you
know that this is hardware and yet it's
getting into a soulful place that you
wouldn't necessarily associate with
hardware and I think that what we can
learn from that is fascinating
Evan you played a variety of roles
incredible fierce strong subjective
sometimes vulnerable what was your
approach to playing Dolores who is
relatively gentle in the beginning but
then obviously has a turn of character
and realization and tell us about your
experience in playing this character
with sharp edges
i its heart it's almost hard to talk
about because I get really emotional
because it did working on the show
changed my life in many different ways
and she was such a gift to be given and
I didn't I knew I was going to be on an
incredible show and I had read the pilot
when I signed on and it was brilliant
and I had heard Jonah and lisas kind of
pitch which really was in retrospect a
lot of information and I knew that that
I wasn't going to stay this kind of
damsel in distress but I would become
strong but my little brain didn't go
much further than that or didn't fully
grasp how deep it was going to go and
just how profound it was going to be and
how she finds her strength I had no idea
and and again as we were getting as the
scripts were coming in and I was and I
was reading it and I'm starting to grasp
what show I was on and you happen to get
existential crisis and ask myself all
these questions and realizing that I was
sort of at the forefront of this
responsibility I almost had a panic
attack I think it around the fourth
episode because I realized what was on
my shoulders and was terrified that he
just got so excited and I was so ready
and I believed in it so much and I just
threw myself in and it really is working
on the show as an immersive experience
it's like going into the park because
the steps are so massive and you're in
everyone is as a character and speaking
differently and moving differently and
everywhere you look is this set and it's
it's unlike anything you've ever seen so
you really do fall into a kind of dream
when you walk in and I just loved the
different layers of her I loved working
with the directors and with Jonah and
Lisa figuring out what this character
was because it's the first season I mean
we all kind of were building a tone
together and a
kind of inventing a style that was
really unique and so finding that and
doing those diagnostic scenes you know
with Jeffrey and then working on every
beat every moment and everything that
she's thinking and all the different
modes she's in and and finding different
variations on that and trying different
things and it's so fulfilling because
especially as women and Aronoff this is
true for men too but a lot of times you
feel like your wings have been clipped
and you're not being represented the way
that you want to and this was just like
somebody had given me a [ __ ] condor
wings and I was I got to take off and
fly and and I'm tearing up just talking
about because it's so important and it's
so important right now and to be a part
of that and to go on that journey with
her and just learn things about myself
and to put my own experiences into what
she was going through and using that as
a vehicle to walk through my own false
reality or my own repressed memories or
trauma and breaking through and coming
out on the other side I mean it was just
transformative and fun I mean good lord
all these people are like family to me
now and because we went on this crazy
journey together and me what we're being
called upon to do and the emotions we
have to conjure up and because there was
so much riding on it we just gave
everything I would come I would drive
home covered in bruises and blood and be
happy because it was for something
amazing that meant something um so it
was it was fantastic
Jeffrey we all thought that Bernard was
one of the few non hosts on the show but
in retrospect there was always something
very reserved and precise about him how
did you how did you pull out that
nuanced portrayal and at what point did
you learn that Bernard was a host well I
you know in this instance in the case of
last season I did know a little bit more
than and some others I didn't know when
I read the pilot I just thought he was
you know every man you know kind of
walking us through this world kind of
detective like but then when we came
back to go into full production the
beginning of episode two Lisa pulled me
aside and and dropped the hammer onto my
head which was I didn't know the full
extent of what it meant but it was and
then I didn't appreciate at that time
really to some extent at all what it
meant I knew that it would be kind of an
interesting foil to play but I think you
know going to the course of the season
and into this season starting to
understand the opportunity there really
as an exercise yes for an actor but also
into some of your points it's kind of an
existential metaphor really interesting
ideas about perception for us reality
consciousness and the decisions that we
make the agreements that we make with
ourselves toward certain touchstones
whether it be physical or metaphysical
familial or regional and the
and and the agreements we make with one
another that determine you know what it
is we're doing right now and I didn't
sleep last night so I have no idea what
that is I was filming until like 4:30 in
the world but um so so I didn't know you
know very early on and I'm still
learning I guess still learning exactly
Banaras join me James
Teddy's loyalty to Delores was
unwavering was something more than his
code or his program something more than
his kilograms yeah I like to think so
yeah I think Teddy and Delores represent
this romantic core of they represent
hope they represent purity and Jonah and
Lisa brilliantly take that and slowly
start to turn it on its head but a lot
of that core of how he feels about
Delores is still there and I think she
still reciprocate that but it becomes
more complicated as the season goes on
as the first season goes on but um yeah
it's interesting how in the first season
you know he felt like he needed to
protect Delores and then he realized she
was fine late in the game but um I don't
know I I love how these hosts represent
sometimes the best of what humanity is
about and I see that in the relationship
between Teddy and Delores and how the
hosts can be sometimes more human than
the humans that come to the park and it
generates great empathy from the
audience hopefully
and we'll continue to as long as that he
can stay on his feet and not on the
floor dead using gloves which stays in
your ears for like weeks in the shower
like blood did I answer your question
perfectly answered Jimmy there's an
interesting juxtaposition in the show
where the hosts inch closer to
consciousness / humanity over time while
your human character liz's humanity over
time what do you think was the tipping
point for William well you know I mean I
think sometimes hard I I think a lot
about this show not quite as much as
Evans she definitely she comes to work
with PowerPoint saying okay this is what
I got
what do you think but I do think a lot
about humans and and hosts and and I
think about this romantic tragedy of
William and Dolores and yet William
turns in a way but I still think that
the human being a slave to one's own
emotions is is uh is like a flaw only a
human will ever have Dolores will never
quite know the way a broken ego
destroyed man will be grasping and
reaching for ways to cover up their own
anguish and so yes he's being harder but
I think he's becoming even more human
he's becoming even more fragile while
less you know while he puts up this huge
like kind of like know I'm strong but I
think there's actually a deep broken
weakness in there so and I think it
started with the first time he fell
deeply in love and
then had that heart broken and I think
you know that can send the best of us
flying over the edge and it turns
William into it
[ __ ] Ed Harris yeah I got damn it I
don't know my own strength
it's the question for the whole cast
what was the most challenging scene for
you to play and why and also conversely
what was the most joyful or fun seem to
do honestly one of the hardest things
for me to shoot was when Jimmy put on
that black hat and here it was one of it
but there was a lot of there was not a
lot of emotional it wasn't like an
intense crazy scene I mean and also the
scene I had with Ed at the end of
episode 10 when we when I fight back
that was super intense and really hard
but that was different because we had
built this this love story together and
really invested in it and really cared
and really wanted to make them fall in
love and we didn't know I mean we kind
of started having a feeling where it was
going
but but but it wasn't until we were
there and I looked at Jimmy and he was
in the black and we both we couldn't
even look each other in the eye that day
we just kept yeah it was it really was
that was emotional just yeah that was
like the rumor this is because they had
crafted the love story so beautifully
that we're like no that's not nothing
bad gonna happen and then it did we were
so nice he do it was too much I think
for me was the most difficult
challenging stuff was to be tortured for
the course of a week with by Anthony
Hopkins once it was revealed that you
know Bernard really was who he was and
was trying to go back into his in
whose memories and experiences in Qatar
figure more out but at the same time in
and I the natural joy working with
everyone but maybe the most enjoyable
scenes were those same scenes you know
maybe that says something about me I
don't know but uh I think it says more
about just working with Tony so yeah one
of the same I'd say the the one on the
same but most joyful and most difficult
scene for me and I have to be careful I
answer this because on the back of this
card insist please be aware that many
members of your audience may be under
the age of 18 you're right oh we're all
watching with like gentlemen until
you've ridden a horse falls to the wind
as it were you will not know true terror
or to joy
[Laughter]
season two begins with you riding that
horse don't let you I want to ride a
horse naked you really notice a an
interesting question this was an
aggregation from the internet the first
season of Westworld really broke through
became a part of the zeitgeist in
arguably while the season was airing was
there a moment of cultural reference or
perhaps an endorsement or sense that it
was resonating with people or that you
had a feeling that you were part of
something special that was actually
there's an SNL reference I remember
right under like an SNL reference
early yeah I think it was when I was in
target and someone yelled out freeze all
motor functions hahaha that's when I
knew it was the accent it doesn't work
does a fly on Hillary Clinton's face
during the day
remember that around the time the
episode was airing I was in the Atlanta
Airport and there was a piano and
someone was just playing in the middle
of the terminal and they were playing
the west-world theme song and it was
like the third episode of just aired it
out I was Anna I was in a American
football match in New York and I was
taking a train back into back into
Manhattan and there was a huge amount of
drunk guys I haven't just watched this
football match all in these football
jerseys and they were just going because
runs rain or Westworld violins are like
Harlem ends and they were just shouting
it's not that like wow this is the site
guys capturing thing and I just strung
down in my kind of amazing hi so my name
is John [ __ ] a big fan you guys are all
beautiful by the way my question is
actually for Teddy James my prince
from enchanted but you have died quite a
few time so which is your favorite just
like you the only thing I can speak to
really um thank you for that that's very
good today um you know I treat all my
desk evenly I love them equally as I do
my children go to choose one death over
the other would be difficult I like to
anywhere hose down in the intake room
yeah that was um that was a pilot yeah
yeah was laying in a about three inches
of waters that we were I was sharing
with about forty other background
players who were fully nude we got to
know each other really well that day I
wouldn't call it fun but it was
memorable I don't know I honestly can't
pick one I think um it's always very
tragic when petty has to say goodbye
because it's the first time for him
every time yeah thank you
it's like it's like the Kenny of
Westworld
I've heard that one Hey
next questionnaire from that Lander
hello my name is Branden a simple
question we all saw this samurai's
towards the end of the season how much
if any is that going to play a role in
season two you wanted to play a role
doesn't look like anything to me all
right thanks
it's defense yeah beautiful so I love
Westworld obviously there's so many
memorable various heartbreaking scenes
were there any scenes and this is for
the whole cast when you read the script
you were just so excited to begin
filming or were there any scenes you
didn't want to really film you weren't
very excited for well speaking
personally when I read the scene were
Dolores you know beats me up drags me in
a church dislocated my shoulder and it
tells me at the back door of the church
I was tremendously excited never means
one of the most joyous experiences that
I've had because Evan was so effing
excited to do that this made me feel
good I was really nervous to shoot
scenes in cold storage remember the day
that Timon I did that because there's a
combination of fake nude people in real
nude people and I was just really
nervous about looking down as I was
doing constantly and I had a flashlight
and I was just like what you did in
people's crotches maybe like go up with
a flashlight it was like that kind of
thing where you'd read something and
then you just do it that's what I did
I was in Spain shooting a film and I got
the I think at the time the 6th episode
and when I read the script and I saw
that scene where Clementine is in the
laboratory and beats the [ __ ] out of
that guy I literally wrote to Anna's
that and Lisa and said thank you for the
rock because it's a really emotional
scene and a very empowering scene you
kind of see the transition and
Clementine for the first time and I mean
it was awesome thank you yeah I mean my
scene no I
I just want to personally also thank the
equalization of the sexes in the show is
incredibly empowering it's something
that resonates with me as a viewer is
something that made me fall in love with
[Applause]
X question has to be from someone
wearing some kind of patriotic guard
okay hey everyone my question is for
daddy actually I loved Maeve on the show
her Ark is amazing in season two as an
actress would you like to see her use
whom humanity to journey inward or
simply controlled them the way she does
host Oh such a difficult such a
difficult answer to give you
I've never felt like this before I am a
control freak and I feel like that's the
way forward to have power in a situation
and we're taking in a professional
environment you know actually being a
woman it's tough see me always looking
over your shoulder you're always
checking in with am I being respected
what do I have to do to try and further
my situation and I started out on this
show and it's the weirdest thing like
you're going to be a madam in a saloon
you're going to be naked 75% of the time
and there's me like I really want to try
and further my empowerment of women and
them but they obviously explained you
know where would be going and for the
first time in my professional life and I
would honestly say like in my personal I
do I have complete trust and faith in
what these people are writing and in
where they're taking the show to the
point where I have no idea and I am
excited to find out what it's going to
be because I know absolutely that I
couldn't predict how tremendous how
inspiring is going to be I don't have it
in me but these people do and it is the
most extraordinary feeling to be able to
surrender and to trust the way we get to
trust so I don't know that I can't
[ __ ] wait to find out
[Applause]
you